nobody's put this [__] film together
you're gonna have to say goodbye to your
loved ones on facebook let's get a big
bag of popcorn everybody's crying you
know what i'm saying i've been waiting
for dine on facebook peter lucas
whatever the rat i can't take it no more
one of the moms ate a gummy tremendous
this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house
what's happening you bad [__]
sorry about monday but it's wednesday
the joint is brought to you by who do
you think on a month on a wednesday
morning blue chew listen if april
showers bring may flowers it's time to
plant your seed and give your lady a
nice white stabbin type of shower blue
chew is tremendous no drama they taste
great you can pop them anytime any day
and you're saying but uncle joey
you're a [__] old goat my hammer of
death is still working yeah but guess
what you want it to work 110
you want to go in there and rip [__] up
you understand me you want her to call
you and say no moss i can't take it you
destroyed it the process is simple you
sign up at bluetooth.com and you talk to
one of the licensed medical providers
once you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
is it's all online no doctor's office no
pharmacy no [__] judgment it ships
right to your door in a discrete package
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and they're way cheaper than the
pharmacy so if you can benefit from a
little extra confidence if you know what
that's what they want to call it i call
it showing up there with a with a bat
that's going to hit a [__] grand slam
so if you can perform like that
don't you want to be with blue chew so
do your favorite blue chew can help you
out they'll make you a [__] stabbing
it comes in a little package you can put
it in your wallet and it don't matter
you can take it anywhere anytime on an
empty stomach you'll be [__] rocking
and rolling within 30 minutes hitting
yourself on the head
so do yourself a favor
go to
bluechew.com right now try bluetooth for
free
how [__] good who shows up with a
[__] hard-on on a wednesday uncle
joey does at [__] seven in the
morning
so go try bluetooth for free when you
use promo code joey j-o-e-y and check
out just pay five dollars for shipping
i'm hooking you up today that's
bluechew.com
promo code joey to receive
your first month
free
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and i want
to thank
blueshoe.com for sponsoring the podcast
the joint is also brought to you by
relief band listen a lot of people got
plenty to be anxious about so when uncle
joey says relief bad helps me with my
anxiety you know it's the real deal
relief bad has been clinically proven to
quickly relieve and prevent
anxiety-induced nausea guess what i did
this weekend i got sick but towards the
end of the second day i charged up my
relief band and it got me through the
nausea it's like the name says it's a
band you wear on your wrist to give you
relief from nausea caused by anxiety
hangovers cause sickness you change the
intensity depending on how you're
feeling to make it stronger or weaker
listen i don't know if you got anxiety
but this can help by your uncle your
aunt maybe grandma grandpa
relief man is 100 drug free non-drowsy
and provides long-lasting relief with
zero side effects and they just relief
the release the relief band sport it's
waterproof has an extended battery life
and attaches to your apple android watch
make relief band
a great gift any time of year like i
said you got an aunt an uncle i'm gonna
save you 20 percent if you go to
reliefband.com and use promo code joey
i'm going to save you 20
and free shipping with no questions
asked
return how's that who takes care of you
like uncle joey on a wednesday nobody
and they got a 30-day money-back
guarantee listen when i got the watchers
from my surgery and it was two years ago
it's still ticking and i still use it if
you got anxiety a little nausea when you
fly this is the way to go relief band r
e e l i e f
b and d dot com
use promo code joey for 20 off and free
shipping the joint is also brought to
you by the best
cbd lion last week i got a little twitch
on my shoulder you've been standing
there and you got a little muscle twitch
in your shoulders sometimes from working
out i put that little c uh cbd line
tape on my shoulder nothing brand new
some night sometimes at night
i can't roll over on my shoulders
because my shoulders just hurt at night
i put a little piece of tape on i'm
doing [__]
i'm doing spinnerets on my [__]
shoulder listen to me cbd lion as far as
i'm concerned is the best
help you a little anxiety helps with
inflammation which is the cause that's
destroying you and slowing you the [__]
down every time you drink milk eat sugar
all that [__] cbd lion has gummies
medicated gummies with melatonin
you know bath balls the cream the
tincture the chocolate
it's just they never end and everything
is 100
everything is solid even this this delta
eight they got the gummies oh [__]
grow hair on your chin i ate some of
them last night i woke up all [__] up
this morning so do yourself a favor when
you're thinking about cbd go to
cbdline.com and pressing code joey joint
or church and get 20 off your order
let's get this [__] party started
[Music]
welcome to uncle joy's joy
what's happening you bad [__]
we're back it's a beautiful day to be
alive wednesday april the [__] 13th
i'm sorry about monday listen guys
let's talk about this [__] you know
for the last 10 and i don't want to
bring it up but i got it
and now they're doing it again for the
last two years
all you hear about is [__] you know
how you're going to get this
how you going to die how it's gonna go
in your chest you're gonna have to say
goodbye to your loved ones on facebook
you know i'm still waiting for the pilot
to dine on facebook a hundred people
thousand people died nobody saved the
video of their uncle going i can't take
it no more whatever let's put them
together let's do a [__] movie at a
movie theater everybody's looking for
the next big [__] idea i've been
waiting for dying on facebook for two
[__] years nobody's put this [__]
film together please people it's over
you've warned them already take the
footage of them dying with the tube in
their nose let's put the film together
let's get a big bag of popcorn
everybody's crying you know what i'm
saying coverts gonna [__] kill you
but in that whole [__] time then you
say who gods about the [__] stomach
flu that's going around where was this
stomach flu invented in a [__] bat
cave also jesus christ listen i had
covered
granted i had the gay variation the
[__] omnicom whatever the [__] it is
i'm the crown he did you know he didn't
show up with a full [__] set of
bullets you know what i'm saying he
showed up with like two bullets you got
a headache and a [__] stuffy nose get
your [__] together that's the one i got
i got the little [__] you know i got
the the the peta like the what's the
worst apostle i don't even know anymore
you know what i'm saying yeah like well
i don't know peter lucas whatever the
rat you know
[__]
this stomach flu i had last week would
[__] the [__] cove it up it would
[__] it up it was nothing guys it was
nothing coveted got nothing on the
[__] stomach flu nothing i saw my
what bro i was talking to my wife and
all of a sudden you know she comes back
like somebody hit in the head with a
ball of gin she's american indian so you
never know what these [__]
she's she's [__] you know looking
around like oh what's the match because
i don't know jerry i feel and i don't
feel good you know my wife has that
we're getting older all right go lay
down [__] i come back i took mercy to
the school chick-fil-a [__] reunion i
like chick-fil-a whenever they have
those nights where if you go and spend
and donates to the school i call people
chick-fil-a's the hot joint tonight and
it was like three parents were talking
[__] one of the moms ate a gummy
tremendous but i think of the
chick-fil-a when i got back i brought a
chick-fil-a for my wife because that's
what you do and she's like that's the
last thing i want to see she was in the
shower laying down
just puking in the shower with a poor
thing in a bucket
and i'm like what the [__] happened
she's telling me all this the next day
she was out of commission and you know
me and my daughter had to do without you
know i don't know if i talked about on
the podcast you know now nobody wants to
hear if you're [__] sick anymore
everybody's been sick for [__] three
years nobody wants to hear it no more so
i [__] uh
you know wednesday was just a [__]
ho-hum day here we fend for ourselves
and you know we did little things
thursday she started feeling better but
next thing you know my daughter's
[__] ill now we got her out of school
she's barfing dog she was fine she had a
piece of ice cream and it just [__]
went out of her mouth tremendous down
for the night didn't even say good night
so she didn't go to school friday
so i'm fine you know i'm looking at all
this chaos in my house people [__]
i'm smelling odors and [__]
i mean i felt really bad for my [__]
wife
because she was uh
you know she was just [__] wiped out
i mean she it just wipes you the [__]
out for some reason
so friday i was like [__] you know i'm
feeling okay and i did what i had to do
i
had a few meetings had to do something
for drafting
and the next thing you know it was like
in the afternoon i'm like something
[__] right here you know just
something didn't for you know when you
don't feel right it wasn't my stomach i
didn't have diarrhea
i just wrote it off the friday you know
like friday at four you're like
i'm feeling a little run down today like
that's how i was feeling okay
you know no big [__] deal so
i don't know what we did friday night
you know i don't eat [__] on friday
because there's no meat so i probably
have like an egg salad [__] sandwich
and in fact that's what i did happened
then i had an egg salad [__] sandwich
and you know nothing really crazy i
don't know what we were supposed to do
or whatever
and guys the next thing you know i'm
like you know what i want to get up
early saturday i had a couple [__]
things to do
and i took my little cvs gummies they
sell these over the county gummies at
cvs to help you sleep remember i told
you guys i got to alternate everything
so some nights it's a [__]
some nights it's uh you know nyquil
without the quill
and some nights uh i do the gummies some
nights i do the cbd
last night
i did the [__]
dc whatever the [__] those things are
i did the cbd lion delta hey guys i'm
still [__] up today i ate him a little
late because i had a little insomnia
late night but
i was [__] up so anyway i ate these
little grape gummies
no big deal i eat them one night a week
i buy them twice a month maybe once a
month
i eat like 10 of them
regular people are supposed to eat two
and i ain't regular so i ate [__] 10
of them because i want to sleep like a
baby and i got the great flavor like it
just tastes different this grape you
know so [__]
it's like 10 o'clock i'm talking to my
wife it's like nine o'clock and my wife
goes i'm going upstairs you know do what
you need to do i was just gonna finish
up some paperwork
and i ate these [__] gummies and i'm
eating the gummies and doesn't even dawn
on me and now i'm feeling it i go
upstairs i go [__] i'm gonna go to bed
and i go upstairs
it's about 11 o'clock i'm minding my own
business and next thing you [__] know
i gotta barf
i gotta barf again i gotta barf again
i gotta barf again i go [__] three in
the morning what am i gonna do i'm not
gonna sleep obviously there's a
barfathon
i came down here and i [__] watch
some tv and you know but then i barfed
down here and then one time i almost
didn't make it i had to puke a half a
puke in the tub in the bucket and i was
like that's it that's what my wife was
barfing outside and next thing you know
i just ran upstairs and i don't know
what he would even take and i think i
drank a little pepto-bismol
but it was [__] cold my wife put in
the refrigerator what the [__] is in the
refrigerator for i like it nice and warm
that pink little [__] when you drink it
night for your stomach it takes those
little pains away those little things
and [__]
so i drank the [__] pepto-bismol and
that settled it and i fell asleep and
guys
i woke up to this is exactly what i
heard in my head
hell is coming for breakfast it's a
scene from [__] the outlaw josie
wales when he shows up and he's got the
gun in his hand in his hand with the
white sheet on it he played a fake
surrender
you know how josie does it he don't
surrender he played a fake [__]
surrender and that's from the old no the
old man indian goes oh oh god hell is
coming for breakfast and he just [__]
mangles those [__] [__] anyway
that's what it was hell was coming for
breakfast jack
all i remember was puking
one smooth move
it was a puke and as i went down i was
pulling the back of my shorts down so i
could do the quick turnaround to
hopefully land my [__] right in the
middle so the explosion from my diarrhea
that's about to come out and that's
exactly what happened i barfed a little
bit
and i turned real quick and as i was
pulling my shorts down that little
stream of black liquid was coming out
mixed with chicken bones and bubble gum
from the sixth grade and [__]
when that hit that [__] thing and i'm
like oh thank god i made it and all of a
sudden i'm like woo right like i got it
this is something out of a [__] movie
guys i'm like
i got it i missed it because you don't
want to you know you're sick you don't
have to clean up the boot you have to
wipe some [__] down then when you get
better you go in there with the lysol
and the [__] cleaner
guys and all of a sudden i'm sitting i'm
like oh i made it bro it was like the
time i went to san francisco and i said
san francisco's changed and some guy
walked at me with a big dick painting to
see spray painted himself all naked and
i'm like i smoked too quick same [__]
thing i was like
i made it and all of a sudden i just
felt it
like my eyes just opened and i could see
my wife coming to check on me and i
could i go terry get the book
the bucket you know like the little
garbage bucket and dog i gotta be
honestly and this is where the story
ends
she missed the bucket you know i missed
up what am i saying she missed the
bucket it's me puking i'm doing the puke
and i missed the [__] two points
but this was the [__]
crazy thing like i put she put the
bucket like by my chest level but when
it came out guys
the enforcer came out with it just went
up
and all i heard it was hit the tub
that's four feet away guys
at that point i thought i was a [__]
dead man
and after that one was when my head
started pounding because i was
definitely dehydrated listen
thank god again for liquid [__] iv
thank [__] god that's why i got a
little bit of water here you haven't
heard it and then i got my little uh bit
of liquid iv because i'm still [__]
recovering you know what i'm saying
so
that was it for me guys once i bought
that i remember like
i even helped her pick up the bathroom
carpeting
the shower carpeting the little [__]
island that sits around the toilet that
smells like 10 dead pisses
because it's my piss that falls on there
i can't hit it with the turtleneck
sometimes
dog we just put it all in the hamper and
she said leave it i just wipe my face
i put an ice bag on my neck
and i tried to lay down there was no
sleep you sleep for 25 minutes
and you got to go to the bathroom for
10. you sleep for 25 10 and that was
basically it till [__] saturday that
was all day
and then saturday you're just sitting
here thank god for my [__]
producer of the year who said smoke a
little you know when i get sick like
that smoking is the last thing i think
of believe it or not
it really is a real guy as it really is
i can't you know you can't put marijuana
on everything i cannot say i cannot tell
people that marijuana cures at all you
know what i'm saying i was having a
conversation with leia at the park and
she goes do you think nice lady
husband's a cop and she goes do you
think that marijuana take i'll tell you
what man
i'm not gonna put this on a
documentation but i'll tell you what
works for me
there was a time
30 years ago i had a [__] toothache
so severe there was two times i remember
it was probably
20 years ago in boulder when i was just
starting comedy i was flat broke and
there was maybe a situation
when i lived in hollywood one holiday
they broke and i had a toothache and the
doctor couldn't see me till like the
third of january and i went those 10
days with no oxy no nothing
just straight up and i finally go let me
try the reefer and i'm going to take
some of my marijuana with a toothache
this is for uncle joey if it takes you
somewhere
it won't take care of pain but some way
or another it gets your mind thinking so
you actually forget about the pain
it's really interesting how marijuana
works for pain and then when you
remember the pain you visit it you're
like oh [__] was it the marijuana or was
that i took my mind off the pain it's a
really interesting concept when you
[__] think about what happened and it
works for me guys i'm not gonna you know
do you think the marijuana helps my knee
pain no you know i'm saying so i don't
want you to say well [__] dog and
that's the same thing i say about cbd
for some people
you know what man i love cbd line it
works for me the [__] gummies work
for me the patch works for me i've been
rubbing the cream into my knee guys
i had another cbd line you know me i
like to at least try
i didn't you know what i'm saying like
it just didn't work for me
but they had a gummy that i felt i was
[__] so you understand me everything
hits you differently when you judge that
stuff for me
i didn't think about marijuana that day
at all i was feeling like i was gonna
die
and i was coughing you know obviously
you could tell i got some type of
[__] lung thing going on
so i was like i don't think then i
smoked and i'm like okay the first two
hits were a little rough i'm not gonna
lie to you but then like the fourth hit
i'm like okay now i can have chicken
soup
so i was like [__] i gotta put a
feather in mikey's cap
[__] chicken soup because i told mike
mike i don't know about tomorrow because
if i would have just got sick guys
and that's it
you could write it off to something you
had a bad hot dog you had a bad fruit
you know there's a thousand things you
could write after but when three people
in your house get it it's pretty simple
that it's a virus it's contagious
so we had to cancel
monday
or it hits you in two days we all got
clobbered within [__] 48 hours so
mike wouldn't be here wednesday though
somewhere or another i was going to
short you this week so my apologies the
other situation is you know what it's
easter week what the [__] you people
going to be traveling [__] smoking
dope having a great [__] time with
your family so you know enjoy
[__] i know a lot of you is like
listening to the podcast and stuff we
got some [__] out we got some stuff
worked out but it's not even about that
it's easter week enjoy your family enjoy
your [__] surroundings eat some
[__]
hard-boiled eggs fart on the plane on
the way home on the bus
i love this time of the year i'm gonna
have a good time sunday
i don't know what i'm gonna do i'm not
concerned with it yet but i'm concerned
i want to talk to you guys about
something that came
to my mind yesterday i had to do
something
and i had a specific time i had to be
there like the guy goes if you could be
back
by two o'clock you know it would be
great
but if it's a situation i go no no i'll
be there at two o'clock you know and uh
this is one of these stories for you
guys that i i haven't i didn't remember
this [__]
but i thought about it at that time and
it was
so helpful to me you know
when i first got the longest yard it was
when i shot the movie it was march
i think i started shooting a movie in
may of 2004
and you know i didn't think anything of
it guys i just
got the movie i went to santa i went to
wherever
santa fe new mexico and i shot the movie
and i was there for about six weeks and
then i came home and
my agent said to me you know do you know
how long you're going to be home for and
i go yeah i'm going to be home for in
and we're shooting to november or
december it doesn't really matter we're
talking about august now i'm not
thinking about the future
my agent says to me there's a couple
companies that want to meet with you
i got you like 20 [__] meetings so
shoot me a schedule and i'll book the
meetings around
your uh
your movies or what do you stand up you
know so no problem
i
shoot shooting the schedule and a couple
days later
i go to jerry's deli
in the valley
just to write or something like that and
i see an agent up there
was i tight with the agent not really i
knew him from being out and he knew me
you know hello goodbye basis i was just
thinking about the story in the
mentality just to let you guys know
so we're sitting at the table i don't
know he comes over to my table we start
talking he goes do you mind if i sit i'm
meeting one of my other clients there
and i go no problem
and the client walks in he's a friend of
mine you know like i know him from the
comedy scene it's like we jump up and
down together
but he's sitting there this guy's a
pretty popular comic at the time you
know
he wasn't a star by any means
but his star was rising funny guy you
know like i said i didn't
run with him in general circles and that
was the client he was meeting so we all
sat together and you know one thing came
up to the other blah blah blah
and when the guy saw me he was trying to
steal me you know what i'm saying like
he was
trying to impress me or something i i
didn't know why i was pretty happy where
i was
it wasn't like i was out i was just out
trying to write jokes and i want to get
an egg cream and maybe a bagel
that's the only reason you go to [__]
jerry's they're closed now and the food
ended up sucking dick towards the end it
was gets god awful the last [__] five
years but that was 2004 and
what they wanted to say to me was listen
man you're going to get busy they were
trying to like blow smoke in my ass like
hollywood i don't know if you guys are
watching winning time on la it's a show
about the lakers in 1980 how they
started their run for the championship
with magic johnson [__] interesting
as [__] that kid riley
that he took that role as dr jerry bust
if he doesn't win the actor of the year
for this role i'm [__] done watching
tv and i'm not even a big fan of his i'm
a fan of his work i i met him at us adam
sandler thing i didn't really say much i
didn't know what to talk about me i
loved you and boogie nights you know
but this guy for years i've heard how
powerful an actor he is oh my god if
you're not watching winning time on hb
[__] oh it's interesting you know
magic johnson's [__] on the phone
with his mother and she's like are you
eating good and you see him eating some
[__] black chick and then are you
going to church and he's banging another
one doggy style and [__] it's crazy it's
a great show very
very entertaining especially if you knew
what was going on at that time and i
lived on that that was
magic versus larry bird that was the
beginning of the whole thing but what my
point is i'm getting because there's a
scene in there where he has to go to a
meeting to sell sneakers and i got like
flashbacks this is what makes me talk
about this story about these meetings
that you go to they wait for you and
they have like a mug with your name on
it for you and they're like joey we
loved you you know what i'm saying that
and you sit there and you go what the
[__] do you want
you know the meetings are in the morning
that means they're serious about this
meetings but the meetings at 4 45
that means you're their last 15 minutes
until they get the [__] out and they'll
tell you when they walk in i don't have
much time and you're like well i'm happy
you're saying that because i just drove
an hour and a [__] half and i had to
do this to get to this [__] meeting
you know
so you bump into a lot of these means
well hi how are you
dog you just go holy [__]
how how much do they pay you
to act this way like hi oh my god we're
so happy you're here we are so excited
to work with you
it's going to be an honor
you know and you're like
you [__] thieve [__] you
know
so
that's why i'm thinking about this story
because of winning time with the
meetings
and what this guy in this comedian they
were trying to lure me into that pen at
the time i don't know where that
comedian is and i don't even know where
his agent is anymore those [__]
disappeared and you're gonna know what
and they were they were coaching me
like listen bro i take coaching from
[__] stars okay if you want to
[__] coach me like i i i'll sit and
listen and give you the respect you
deserve
but
i don't even know you
and in la there's a lot of those type of
[__] people that they you know just
jump into your life guys and you're like
who the [__] are you i don't even know
you what are you talking about
so
they're telling me that you know when i
start going to these meetings i have to
be late
they're like you have to be late for
these meetings always keep these
[__] waiting
that's the market where he goes you're
not a tv guy you're in a [__] feature
film
that means something nowadays he goes
you got to go to all the meetings when
people invite you to meetings you're
always going to be late whether they're
social
or whether they're going to be uh
personal in business because you always
want to give
people the idea that you're so much more
busy than they are and that your life is
worth something and i'm like
my life ain't worth [__] i just did a
[__] movie
they pulled me in the movie not because
of my acting [__] range or anything
because i'm the only 400 [__] fat
[__] they could find you know let's be
honest with us i mean you know what i'm
saying even at that point i'm like
what are these guys talking about
they're like you always want to be late
keep them waiting i know and they
started naming all stars you have to
wait a half hour for them and they call
the restaurant to make sure you're there
you know something like [__] like that
guys that
you know i'm from jersey i'm a dirty
jersey guy what the [__] do i know about
[__] being late if you're late you're
late you know i got hit by a [__]
pigeon on the way here you know i hit a
[__] deal whatever the [__] happens
to you
so they're telling me all this [__] and
guys i gotta be honest with you at first
i was like
i don't know you know and i wasn't gonna
ask my man rogan that's the dumbest
[__] question that's
right there i should have known if it
was too dumb to ask joe i shouldn't
[__] ask the [__] question what
i'm saying like
and i knew it was too dumb to ask joe so
right away i got put on a [__] couple
meetings and [__] i'd sign with this
arabian manager sweetheart of a guy i
don't even know what happened to him he
came to me like five years ago i'm like
how you doing he goes you remember me
i'm like not really he changed
completely this guy he signed me he was
like a hot up-and-coming manager and
he was looking for a guy that read
scripts and he was looking he wasn't
looking for me at the time he was
looking for the comic i became
but at the time in 2004 i wasn't that
comic you know not by a long shot i
wasn't that comic
so we lasted about three months and he
was an aggressive [__] dude i had
forgotten all about that i worked with
this guy and you want me to tell you
what the interesting thing was when he
i worked in him in 2004 let me see i i
came home from shooting a movie maybe in
august of 2004 and i worked at this guy
till maybe march or april
of 2005 right before the movie was
released
he had another client that was in a tv
show at the time
and the client was going to go abroad
somewhere and
the client wanted him to go with him
and i remember we were talking about
this for weeks i had a mutual friend
with the client he's not even in
business no more
and uh he was saying that he wanted to
go to this place with him because
whatever
so i knew this was coming but i didn't
know it was gonna affect my relationship
with him but he was his out
he he said he called me one day he goes
i can't
work with you anymore because i'm going
to be out of town for the next eight
months shooting this
if you want i could get find somebody
like no no no and at that time i knew we
were over
because i just wasn't ready for his he
was a
a manager that had real talent you know
like they were together
i wasn't together you know he was
sending memos and [__] to my house and
i'm like he would send memos
like 10 a day and i'm like why are you
sending
these [__] memos every day i don't
want to see this [__]
and you know he was just trying to teach
me about the business but
i didn't want to learn and he [__]
got me he had the guys when i tell you
after the longest yard how many [__]
meetings i had
holy [__] and right now i'm looking back
at you i can only think of like three of
them
like three ex i i never forgot the tom
hanks meeting like i had a little
meeting with tom hanks i never forgot
that i bet you he did
uh
yeah
i had a meeting
with this guy that was so
[__] outlandish
he wanted to put movies up just for me
alone and [__] and then it just got
creepy you know he was going to put up a
two million dollar budget but then about
a month later he called me to borrow 800
bucks
to go somewhere like it was guys there
was it was you know i went into a funk
after the longest yard was released but
leading up to the longest shot this is
my first big thing
so i was getting my feet wet and it was
uh it was [__] i couldn't [__] handle
so i started going you know he started
this
agent
manager that was really trying to help
me after i came home from the longest
yard
sent me on a meeting one time at fox
guys
and you know you guys hear stories about
me being buckwild
guys that [__] hasn't happened
in over 15 years but
until 2006 i had a little [__] flare
to me
and you know
i i try to do my best you know but i
tell you the honest truth on everything
i had this audition for a fox pilot
right [__] tremendous pilot if
anybody was made for that pilot it was
your uncle joey
i read this pilot i studied this pilot
i chopped it up you know somebody told
me that they saw de niro script for
scarface while they were shooting
scarface and it looked like a [__] it
looked like a mangled magazine from all
the notes and pictures he takes pictures
and hangs them in there and [__] like
that and that's what i wanted i wanted a
[__] i wanted a role where i you know
i could put all the [__] i did so for
some reason under my cocaine this is the
end of the cocaine tear
i'm reading this [__] thing for a
week preparing for this goddamn audition
in and out in and out i wrote it out i
wrote the [__] script out by hand
i was a pretty good lead this would have
been it was three roommates and i was
the outlandish one and two of them were
divorced and i was the older one it was
it fit like a [__] glove they told
you all the info in this pilot
but for some reason under my cocaine
paranoia mental state i read it a
different way and that happens that
happen you know you don't read [__]
right when you're on [__] drugs
i read it as this guy is a [__]
cokehead
that lives with two [__]
roommates and he's like you know
and he never shaved he was very gruff
all those characteristics of you know he
was paranoid he was always in a bad mood
he couldn't find a job and i'm thinking
to myself in my cocaine mind
but these guys aren't telling me that
he's a cokehead
so the audition was at 10 o'clock in the
morning at fox
what do you think your uncle joey did he
snorted cocaine
till [__] 7 59 a.m to prepare for the
character
you understand me nobody's perfect guys
but at least you got to be able to share
these stories of you [__]
guys i walked in there three sheets to
the wind
coke in my nose i didn't know the coke
was in my nose i sat down
there was four people there there was
like two women
two guys there was a woman that was the
captain kirk of the enterprise
and she's like [__] you know let's go
over this
i did it like two times
guys at the time i thought i was olivier
but guys i got to be honest here just
feeling just thinking this is one of my
darkest secrets i'm telling you he was
god-awful
and i remember laying it out and feeling
like those people that i used to see
like when i go auditions i sit by the
door to see what people are gonna do
when they open the door they tell people
thank you for coming the look on their
face i always said to myself i don't
want that [__] look
i don't ever want that look i know what
that look is to look a [__] should i
shoot myself now or should i wait till i
walk outside the building that's that
look and once you see it you're like
that motherfucker's gonna shoot himself
i was for years i just sat there and
watched people and i [__] it's like
when i sat with rogan in first class and
people walked past me i yelled get to
the dungeon i just tell and they'd walk
past me and look at me and rogan i go
get to the dungeon and they go back
there like roll 29 [__] c in the
bottom of the plane
i don't even know what i was talking
about so [__] it
what we talking about here
[Music]
oh the meeting so i went in there
and i'm [__] two sheets to the wind
and i'm [__]
doing these lines like i'm [__]
olivier and they're looking at me guys
like i just murdered somebody
i think i even put a hole in my shirt
guys it was it was not it was not a good
joe diaz at all
i did like two and they could tell
anybody could tell i was [__]
out of my mind i can't say i was jacked
up and i didn't snort till 8 o'clock
but i didn't sleep
and you know it was one of those things
where you just
don't [__] sleep and go to an
audition
i remember going on audition for
travolta movie and seeing a [__]
tremendous i can't remember what his
name is
this guy was a tremendous [__] actor
he had been on miami vice movies he he's
in the movie uh kiss of death with
nicolas cage at the time we were both
reading for different roles
guys i walked in on a monday i had to
[__] wake him up
give him tissues to clean his nose
i had to bring [__] chatted run and
get coffee and juice for this guy peter
peter something italian guy very good
looking from brooklyn he was good dear
friends with uh like tammy pascatelli
and all those guys i can't remember his
name is sweetheart of a guy and i had to
clean him up i mean and he's like dog
when i woke him up in the audition he's
like
you know that look when you wake
somebody up when they're all [__] up
he was like am i okay you're fine dog
but you can't go into your audition like
this come on and i took him out and i
[__] took care of him i walked in
there in the same part but i swear to
god i had an incident when i was a kid
where i got on a plane i went to order a
drink from the bar because in the 80s
there were planes and bars that you
could walk to and get a cocktail to
stretch your [__] legs and i remember
i went up to the thing and i was all
[__] up and i asked for a drink and
when the guy gave me the drink i had a
little coke rock that was dangling on my
nose and it was a black
countertop and the coke rock
just fell on the counter me and the
[__] bartender just looked at each
other for like two minutes we just
looked at the rock and didn't say
nothing we were both i was embarrassed
as [__] he couldn't believe a white
little rocket and it had like a little
snot around perfect
perfect you and
even a child could go that looks like a
coke rocket even if they didn't know
about coke that was a coke rock and we
just stared each other down i thought he
was gonna call security and next thing i
just looked up and i made believe like
the chip fell off the [__] ceiling
you ever like in a place and a little
piece of paint falls on the table and i
looked at the ceiling and i looked at
the coke rock and i walked away and the
guy's like you can't [__] calm me
with that look
guys the point of the story is i went
into that [__] meeting and i could
feel
the cocaine liquid coming out of my nose
and after about four minutes this lady
goes
i need to have a word with you and i
thought she was gonna
ask the other people to leave the room
no
in front of everybody
in front of everybody she just she
didn't lay into me but she did lay into
me
and she said that you know
she was uh she liked me but that i came
into that thing
over prepared and overstimulated she's
and just it's
she's like i don't know i don't know
what caused the stimulation today but
this is not an audition for the books
and [__] and i was like well what do you
want i mean guys i was out of it i was a
year away from quitting cocaine i mean
obviously by the you could tell by this
story that you know after you go through
one of these you can't keep doing this
[__] although they just won't work you
and
guys i caught myself i did catch myself
you know and
it's always meant the [__] world to
me that shortly after that you know and
i think after that was boilermaker when
they said the word got out that you're a
coke fiend and [__] you know that's a
tough [__] thing to knock down
and i sent her a card
in a letter a couple weeks later and had
a dear friend at fox and i called him
like a man
and i told him what i had done
and he said he would talk to her again
and guess what that dude just called me
he called my agency to talk to me the
agency called me they go we want to talk
they want to talk to you about a project
like oh [__] i haven't heard that name
in 10 years he was a big time at fox for
voiceovers and i just spoke to him and
uh i called him and he's like i'm really
proud of you i can't believe you took my
co-reading class and you did so much
with it christian kaplan i love this
[__]
but uh
i tell you stories like that about how i
failed all that [__] to let you know how
how much i came back but the original
story i was trying to get to was being
late for these things i was some just a
mentality
of somebody telling me that like it
really rang my bell
over the weekend like something just was
like what the [__] happened that day
well all these guys like you gotta be
late and i gotta be honest with you guys
i did it about three times
and i didn't like it i ca to be honest
with you guys i did i think i was late
to two meetings one because of the
advice they gave me and the second one
you just really
there really is [__] traffic but
i after the second time i did it
i was like you know what man
hollywood stars are hollywood stars
tv stars are tv stars
comedy stars are comedy stars but i'm
either
who the [__] am i
to go to a meeting late even if who i'm
meeting with they're [__] [__]
and they're never gonna do anything for
me and then you know because tonight
listen those meetings nine and a half
out of ten times
nothing really happens
you know when they meet you in a
restaurant there's no casting couch you
don't get an opportunity to lick [__]
harvey weinstein's nuts no i'm kidding
you
you know when with these general
meetings and [__] that
you know you go to them like i said
they're in the morning they really want
to do something with you if they're
putting you off for 4 30 it's because
you're their last meeting before the end
of the day and at least they could say
yeah we did five general meetings this
week they used to be called five general
meetings as me and mike meet and we
speak about the project and we we put a
date or time to meet again and if mike
wants to hire me he calls me back if not
he could just tell me whatever the [__]
he wants that's what a general is
that it's to to let
the fox and cbs and
the people in development know that
you're alive
but you only got five minutes to let
them know you're a lot you go in there
you're halfway [__] nervous
and you know you don't do your best so
it for me that never worked out i know i
could give you josh wolfe's number i
give you another a couple other comics
that used to go for generals gone wild
and
nothing really develops in them you know
what i'm saying so
and it really dawned on me how
that whole
story that that not being late
it [__] me up completely because i
remember weeks later me going i'm gonna
get to that meeting late
and i go no i'm not
no i'm not i'm going to leave a half
hour early and allow traffic on the 405
allow traffic on the 10 wherever the
[__] this audition takes me because
that's where you usually go orange
county nothing's around the corner like
here
so
i started being early
15 minutes early 15 minutes early and
guess what guys
it didn't help my professional career as
much as i wanted
but it helped my personal career
to just get you out and guys i was
always one of those [__] that's
on time i don't like starting shows late
i don't like none of that [__]
i understand things happen but
it's just
i know people will be late all their
life and won't expand they won't and the
guy and to be honest here the moral of
the story is
the comedian who was gung-ho about that
telling me how he did it to people he
never shot movies like i did
he's not even around anymore and the
manager that did it he's not around
either that's how much bad [__]
advice is that's how much that's how
much [__] they put into you and you
really don't know
what to [__] believe like you really
don't know you know i don't know what
they tell bands i don't know what they
you know i was watching something the
other day
uh led zeppelin breaking the band on
whatever and jimmy page is one of the
interviews he didn't even have he had an
interview with a chick from cream
magazine
and he wouldn't talk to her
the
interview had to talk to the publicist
and the publicist would have to go in
the other room and bring tell jimmy what
he said and then
no and it's like
that's hollywood behavior that they
allow all that [__]
they allow that from the beginning like
oh he he doesn't want to talk to me you
don't want to talk to me
i'm here i'm here as a fan to help you
expand i'm
i'm not putting you in the school paper
you know what i'm saying i'm here to put
you in rolling stone i'm here to push
you in cream i'm here to put you in gq
or whatever and you don't want to talk
to me
you don't want to [__] look at me i
mean they don't make eye contact you
know how many [__] jobs i went to
well i'll tell you the truth right now
three of them
i went to three jobs for sure where they
told me not to make eye contact with the
star of the show
guys that doesn't work for you that
never worked for a guy like me when you
hear me throw rants like i did the other
day it's not it's not that i you know
it's that
la just does stuff to people that it's
different level and i should not say la
i'm sick and tired of saying that
because la is a very nice place and
there's a lot of great people in l.a
that have great great intentions i
became a great comic from the people in
la helping me and they came in all
different [__] sizes
shapes whatever the [__] you know
but i also knew the evident end was you
have to help yourself
you have to put in the time and collect
the hours and figure out what works for
you but that always dawned on me
and even you know stayed with me years
later
how
they were
it's not fall grooming it's like letting
you know how you have to act
you know i was watching uh
winning on uh
hbo the other night
and it's a scene where dr jerry buss
uh contacts the coach of unlv jerry
tarkanian i don't know if you guys are
up with final four and the [__] you
know jerry tark the shark and all this
[__] that's why it's interesting and he
goes to meet with harry tarkini whatever
and he goes you know i want you to be
the head coach of the lakers
and he goes be out there with those fake
people and i was like wow
you know let me think about this is 19
this show's supposed to be 1980
79 whatever around that time and this
guy's saying fake people
and i started thinking about that after
the show ended
sunday night or whenever i was watching
it because it comes on hbo it's sunday
nights i'm not getting paid for this i
just want you guys to watch good tv on
sunday night you know you don't get paid
for everything some things most things
like to talk about because i enjoy them
other people enjoy maybe i've been
turned on them my friend called me
yesterday he said to watch a show on a
pilot on hbo i didn't know what the [__]
it was it's called the invisible pilot
about a [__] redneck who kills
himself
tremendous no he fakes his own debt
and then he comes back as a drug
smuggler
so nobody really knows he's on the
[__] radar and [__] the first 40
minutes let me tell you something i
almost hung myself three times watching
it because it's just a bunch of [__]
rednecks talking i didn't know what he
did
his next move was gonna be but after
that it just opened [__] up my
brother george turned me on to it the
other night he keeps asking me have you
watch that and i keep breaking this ball
it sucks it sucks it sucks but i watched
episode number two
the other night and they [__] bad you
know what i'm saying i can get fyi guys
i
i i don't know if you're gonna watch
this i don't give a [__] you know a lot
of people come to me and throw show
ideas at me and i'm like guys i don't
even remember that [__] by the time i
get in the car but it's the truth i got
[__] things going in and out of my
[__] coconut i was i was having a
great week last week it ended up i even
booked a voiceover in a film last week
guys
june 30th i shoot it they offered it to
me and it pays it goes towards my
insurance more good news uncle joey got
his [__] insurance again i don't have
to pay 24 [__] 100
a [__] month to a screen actors guild
okay guys i'm 50 [__] i'm vested oh 20
something years in the uni i don't have
[__] insurance you got to help me out
here what the [__] is going on with
[__] society i even got my [__]
freaking fly miles they still got them i
thought they were going to wrap them up
because i haven't flown lately like ah
keep them you were a good man for years
ah
i'll be back [__] i got a great
show tonight
a lot of people are asking me how i feel
and i'm gonna [__] tell you how i
feel
i feel like i did yesterday
i'm a little excited about doing it
i have a couple butterflies
or it could just be gas you know what
i'm saying i got something in there
it's butterflies i uh
i got 10 minutes
guys and for no reason at all do i want
you guys to lose your mind or anything
i got guys when do i get tickets i
really want to see guys
i got 10 minutes
i haven't been on stage
in 13 months
what do you think is gonna happen
do you think i'm gonna go out there and
do lenny bruce live at carnegie hall
are you [__] crazy guys are you
really [__] nuts i'm happy about
wednesday and i'm gonna go there and try
to have the best time i have i can you
know i'm trying to think about
what i want to be different
you know i was talking to my wife the
other night about
i'm not a hundred percent in you know uh
i'm gonna try it a few times and see how
i feel
and leave the door open for the future
but it's not like
i want to go on a [__] tour right now
at all you know
i'm gonna talk to bert and see what
bert's got and see what dates i'm
available to do
uh
you know one of the things you have to
do with comedy that
i never knew what it meant was uh if you
ever listen to synchronicity by police
great [__] album
uh
wrapped around my finger that song
wrapped around my fingers on that and he
says something about you know
he's in love with a married woman in
that song i guess and he goes you know
you
you sold your fate with that wedding
ring in other words that
you booked your future out
you when you came to a relationship you
already booked your future one of the
things i hated i didn't like about you
know because i had to do a george
washington close
you know i put like uh what i liked
about it and what was bothering me
towards the end you know i'm just trying
to be honest with myself guys you know
better help is there for you but they
can't help you all the [__] time
decisions you're gonna have to make on
your own your psychiatrist your parents
your mom your dad this is you're gonna
learn to make on your own so you learn
how to make good judgment calls you know
and if it takes
excuse me writing out a list with the
pros and cons or the position you're
going for
if that's what it takes to let you know
to open up your eyes i'd rather you do
that so you know what you're getting
yourself into
i wish i would have done this more when
i was in my early 20s and mid-30s george
washington close yourself why [__]
around george watson closes pros and
cons right on line to the middle five on
each side let's go what do you want to
do what do you like about it what you
don't like about it and for me i didn't
like
i didn't want i don't like getting
bombarded no more
i enjoy my phone not ringing you know
you know i talked with a lot of my
friends and one was asking me if i
missed the limelight and i'm like not at
all i don't miss any i was never in the
[__] limelight i was in the [__]
shadows
but do i miss no not at all i don't miss
you know i i somebody asked me if i want
to go on a tour and two you know a day
later i was getting calls to book out
the dates you won in june i'm not
prepared for that
i'm not prepared for that you know
i don't you know i don't know if i want
to work june 12th to june 13th i don't
even know i haven't done it in so long
so this is why for my purposes and for
your purposes i mean i've had clubs call
me guys and say listen we heard you're
doing it why don't you just book
september and if you don't want to do it
cancel it
because i don't want to do that to my
people if not i could have done that
already that's what i don't want to do i
don't want to pull a what's a chick who
died
what's that yeah every morning i don't
want i don't wanna i don't wanna pull
her is she coming or not
i don't wanna do that to you you guys
know me that if i don't wanna do
something i'm not gonna go down there
i'm not gonna go down i don't give a
[__] what you got to give i don't give a
[__] you got a reefer you're jumping up
and down if i don't want to go down
there it's not going to happen
so in the last two years i've been
sitting on close to two years i've been
sitting here telling you soon soon soon
and you haven't seen it happen have you
no
the books coming out though may 23rd of
that's the [__] bad news
if they're gonna [__] uh put it
online
thursday or whatever it's gonna be out
like not the book not the print not
pre-order nothing like that no
just to let the
yeah info know that i forget what they
call them um guys
publishing is not my [__]
life here it's you know
but i i don't know what they're gonna
call it or whatever the [__] but i'm
excited we got it out
uh i don't i didn't get anything back
for edits or anything but i did get an
email over the weekend
friday you know when i was my head in
the toilet
that uh we were
publishing on the 20
may 23 of 2012 may 20th of 2020 i will
post up all the available info as i get
it but it doesn't look like it's going
to be this year
does it come with an audio copy and a
flag and a picture of you in an
autograph let's wait for the book to
come out all right
the [__] is wrong with you
are you going to do any book signings i
don't [__] know i don't [__] know
what i'm doing i don't even know what
i'm doing tomorrow i don't even know
what i'm doing today i know what i'm
doing i'm going to get a [__] haircut
because i'm not going on stage looking
like the one thing i like about [__]
winning with my man c riley is that he's
got a tremendous head dude he's got to
wrap it around and comb it and put
[__]
you should have seen my hair
when i [__] was sick the other day i
got up with him because he had to take i
had to keep putting the sleep apnea mask
home taking off keep it on take it off
my hair was just shooting straight up in
the [__] air
it was tremendous but all it was was
[__] white
so i'm shooting i got to do a few videos
and i don't want to shoot it looking
like johnny bumpy so i'm going to get
all done up they're going to trim my
eyebrows today
[__] the hairdo of life i'm gonna be
looking like [__] johnny pop sedara
on 144th
and magnolia boulevard you know what i'm
saying i don't even know what that is
but uh it's been a great week it's gonna
be [__] easter week and as usual you
know
during these times the last uh
um
it seems like more people are dying does
that anybody else
it seems like the last couple years
every
week you get a notice of somebody dying
i've never remembered it like this you
know when i was a young kid i had a
couple years there
where it wasn't [__] kosher but
for the most part it's you know
everybody's been able to keep their
[__] life together
and uh the last two years you know we
lost meatloaf tom patty we we've lost a
lot of i don't know tom petty died
before the pandemic but
yeah we lost a lot of good [__]
people with a pandemic and was trying to
lose you know i was thinking of the
comic the other day and i i remember he
got hit by a car remember the comedian
in texas that got hit by the bus during
the pandemic i forgot what his name is
real talented guy really funny you know
there's been you know jeff the piano
player the store passed away there's
just been
so many people have been off
color you know i really wanted to go to
the store's 50th anniversary last
thursday
and wednesday night i looked online and
looked at tickets and i reserved the
ticket
out of uh
newark for jetblue
i was going to try to leave at 2 in the
afternoon get to l.a like at [__] uh
i don't know what time it was three
thirty give me enough time to get the
it was like i had like a three hour
window
to get the hollywood to the hotel take a
shower and go to the comedy store
reunion you know hari was gonna go steve
simone i really wanted to see those guys
and
i don't know if this would have been an
opening for me to go back
or if this would have been closure i
don't know i wasn't even looking at it
like that but
i wanted to go a part of me was really
enthusiastic about going
so i packed like a half a bag puerto
rican bag and i was like you know what
if anything goes down
i'll just shoot to newark i'm 30 minutes
away
when i look to the thing the original
the first two flights of the day were
already canceled
so i was talking to hari and he goes are
you thinking of flying out and i go yeah
i'm thinking of taking this flight he
goes i don't think they're going to do
it because red is easy just got
cancelled but as easy as not coming in
so
i didn't go to the [__] store 53 and
i spoke to a few people i'm gonna try to
see eleanor thursday night
she's with dice down at uncle vinnie so
maybe i'll go down there she called said
they had a nice time and stuff but
uh yesterday morning i woke up to
again i could tell you a thousand
stories she was just a great sweet kid
from the store
and uh 12 years ago no 10 12 years ago
about 10 years ago mercy's 9.
this was december of 2012.
i uh
you know
flappers called and they said can you
help out jim jeffries this weekend
he's taping he won't be able to get
there late he was taping his comedy
central special and i was like you know
what i'm in town i have to stay close
because my wife is due you know it was
like after the holiday so mercy was born
on the 13th
of january so i remember it being right
before the holidays i wasn't working new
years or maybe i was doing the little
room at the ice house and i was just
dead doing spots guys you know you're
just doing two shows
nothing
i wasn't light in the world on fire
really wasn't my show
so when i got to that 90 minutes girl
and she told me she was a social manager
social media manager
that was new to me you know i didn't i
didn't know what a social media manager
was
and she was very nice and very sweet
and uh
you know i went home that night and the
next day i came back to do the second
the third and fourth show
and one of the comics pulled me aside
and said something to me it kind of was
about me that i had done something
not [__] kosher you know
and i was like guys
i don't know if you know this i did my
set last night
and i just went right home
i parked illegally at flappers i knew
how to park illegally and i had enough
time to do it
and so when i would go to flappers i
would never really hang there's not a
hang at flappers they had a little green
room in the back and they used to give
you use
and i like the uh's and stuff was a
great touch i like flappers and i missed
flappers they stayed open during the
pandemic and i wish them nothing but
well
they're doing great things now so
i that sadly when i came back what the
comic told me was that the girl the
social media girl said that i grabbed a
[__]
and i'm dog my wife is at home pregnant
i'm in i'm in father mode you know i'm
saying i'm not drinking i'm not doing
[__]
and i i go what and i go i'm going here
i go i only met her in here she only
came in here she was in front of you
guys so i had nothing to worry about i
go i met her in here when there was jim
jeffries his his publicist was somebody
else's dad and there was another comic
in there i go no you didn't you guys go
out afterward and i go what
i go no and i left the office
and i went and hunted it down like can i
have a word with you
and she's like what and i go
the comic told me that you're upset with
me because i grabbed your [__] last
night and she goes i don't want to talk
about it
she goes you grab it at the bar and i go
ah
i go hold on one second i went and got
the bartender i go you hey dog because i
was coming in there a lot at the time
i go do i ever come to the [__] was i
in the ball last night goes no
can you talk to me for a second so i i
went and pulled her out and i said
this is what happened you know and
she's like okay well maybe it wasn't you
and i go maybe it wasn't me
that's not the right [__] answer
that's not the right answer
maybe it was
before you make this allegation you
better be damn sure
she was drinking
and she thought i had gone back to the
bar you know i was not at the [__]
bar i don't go to [__] bars no i
don't want to be in buzz
so i you know i don't i went home and
i'm like you know and i started talking
to guys at first i was a little angry
this is before the whole metoo movement
everything but i got a wife at the house
i'm not going out to this grab some
girl's [__] at a [__] thing
so we started talking and we became
friends you know like i you know what
are friends you know hi how you doing
good to see you how's comedy i saw a
couple times and i didn't see her
anymore boom
pop goes to weasel i go to the store
there she is she's a social media
manager
sweet girl she has a boyfriend you know
i talk to her all the time
but
she always wanted more
and and that's all of us guys i can't be
mad at somebody
for somebody wanting more but
for a long time i want it more but you
have to look at your surroundings and
see what you can give yourself and what
you're capable of giving you know i'm
saying she wanted more and she was going
to get it eventually but it was going to
take time like anything else you know
guns and roses put out a great [__]
first down
but they could even a lot better by use
your illusion they got really good by
use your illusion it takes time and more
open open you know then they got a
budget for a [__] eight million
dollar video you know you understand i'm
going with this you know
things are gonna move for you but it
takes time you know
and we'd always chat about comedy and
one night they got into an argument i
don't know what happened she quit the
store
but she's still coming down to do spots
and i would always talk to her very
sweet i bumped into her in vegas you
know tried to give her advice and stuff
and then
she had like you know she would get
drunk and i don't know i don't know what
happened bottom line is yesterday i woke
up
and i saw that picture that you know she
had passed away
on sunday this girl couldn't be
a day older than 35
you know a [__] day older than 35. i
don't even clock her at that you know
i
was tight with her like uh towards the
end you know she would come to me for
advice when i was shooting the sopranos
she was in the city uh doing some
uh chicken video or something like that
and i went to meet her and give her weed
one night she asked me if i was going to
brooklyn and i go no so i gave her 40
for the [__] uh
for the uber whatever you know and then
um in l.a she would be at the comedy
store and i would talk to at the comedy
store and she would always ask for
advice
but i could always see she was impatient
things weren't moving fast enough
and she was
really driven
which i have no problems with all those
three things you know me guys i i
support that
what i don't support is the acceleration
when do you stop and when do you
go up to 60 there has to be
a balance when attacking you have to you
can't always be [__] doing 60. things
are not always going to happen i'm the
most impatient [__] in the world
and i even know that you when you're in
this art game you learn to be patient
[__] is not gonna happen you know it's
gonna be busy for you never mind when
you get into trying to get money from
somebody all you [__] that i'm
gonna make movies and finance films good
luck that's a completely different mind
[__] wait till you ask for 800 million
to give you 800 bitcoins you know trust
me [__]
so this you know and i feel bad because
throughout the day i learned what went
on and
she wasn't happy and she might have
taken her own life i'm i'm saying this
maybe you know
i don't know what happened i wasn't
there
uh sam tripley posted a picture so i
called him last night i go sam
fill me in and we spoke and she was
unhappy and
she was in oklahoma
and when i was withdrawing heavy duty
when i was going still to physical
therapy
she called me out of the blue one day
and said to me that uh
because what happened was listen i know
when somebody's struggling in l.a
i know the look in your eye i know how
people act when they're struggling and i
know how you feel it's a horrible
feeling
when somebody's struggling i'm the type
of guy that
i'll throw you a bone if i see you
struggling in that sense
i'll throw you a well-deserved bone
just to pick up your spirits a little
bit but i can't throw you an opening gig
with joe rogan do you know what i'm
saying like i could throw you a bone i
could get you a gig with dean delray i
could do something in time i could
hustle up something it may not be what
you want
but it's what's coming down the pipe
right now and if you want to work and
get better at your craft
this is the job you're going to accept
she said to keep my eyes open and i
tried to
and she would always contact me for the
difficult
rooms like she wanted to get into this
room and i'm like that guy is not going
to let you go in there right off the bat
you got to go in there with a headliner
and she's like well i don't want to go
in there with a headliner so anyway to
make a long story [__] short
one day i was by the bagel place i was
still coming home from physical therapy
and she called and she said that
she had had a rough pandemic
she had caught a bad case
of drugs you know she she had it bad
with the drugs for a while
she fell into a depression she was going
on through a lot of other stuff in her
life
but she really really wanted to be a
stand-up
and that's why i respected the [__] out
of her
this girl could have been a really good
stand-up in time she just needed time
you could tell when somebody has that
comedic mind lisa
believe it or not as crazy and wack from
torturing and flying jew lee cyan has
got a woody
uh whatever [__] one of those woody
allen minds not that he's gonna go
[__] chinese students or whatever or
chinese daughters of people that are 16.
lee has a very uh
whatever type of mind if lee was done
comedy for eight or nine years lee would
have been really good
his delivery would have been good
but his little off-color jokes are
[__] hilarious
she had that she had that goofiness she
had that innocence so it was gonna work
in time
when i spoke to her
she wasn't in good spirits i don't think
she was very happy with me
because
she came to me once and she goes i
really like to do your podcast when
you're ready when i'm ready
and i said well you let me know when
you're ready you know
at least she wasn't bugging me about the
podcast or anything
so i go let me know when you're ready
guess when she called me
august 14th
right at the end she called me out of
the blue you know the pandemic started
we lost and that's what sam triple he
said when the pandemic started we lost
contact with a lot of those guys because
our communication was the store we
didn't know them from anywhere else so
i lost contact with her and i picked up
my bed she's like hey
can i come on the podcast and i go
you're not going to believe this
because
she always had the worst luck
do you know what i'm saying you know
like she just if she was one of those
people that was a dollar day a
a day late or a dollar short god bless
her
but she [__] uh said i want to do a
podcast and i'm like
you're not going to believe this i just
packed up the studio
and lee just got in this car
and she goes oh so i think in turn she
was kind of angry with me i said you
know i'm not doing it but in time if i
start another one we can do the podcast
you know
when she called me that day she was
talking about that because she had had
an incident at the store they asked to
leave one night
and then they wanted a banner for 30
days i don't exactly know the [__]
story guys but somebody had told me in
george perez the story and we were
talking about it with jeff scott god
rest his soul the piano player in the
back and there must have been a waitress
there or something and she told
sarah god rest her soul that
me jeff and whatever were talking about
it and what were we talking about i was
just explaining to it we were going over
that at the when she called me that day
in the bagel shop maybe uh i don't know
less last march maybe had to be maybe a
year ago
and she was upset and i apologize i said
you know but she was uh
listen i respect your dream but i want
you to keep it in check
i i always respect everybody's dream
but you have to keep it in check and you
have to check yourself on a
monthly basis to see where the [__] you
are if you continue to take what they're
giving you
la is a very hard place
if you're coming from hell if you're
coming from a hell in your life
l.a is not going to be the place right
off the bat in your mind
it's very soothing it's very you know
palm trees you know the eagles haha but
in reality the business of la is a
[__] monster and sometimes if you
come from somewhere where you were in
the hell and you come into la it's not
going to work out for you
and this is what i thought about last
night after i got off the phone with
tripoli
that this uh it didn't work out for this
girl hollywood's a [__]
and all i could say is i i hope the
comics around her and her friends that
were around her
learn that this isn't a [__] joke
anymore they're playing for keeps
and i'm really
sad for her family and what they're
going through and
her friends so my heart goes out to
sarah
and i'll see you on the other side
[__] you were a fun girl and
i'm sorry and that's my podcast
for wednesday the [__] 13th
of april like i said i'm excited about
uncle vinnie's tonight if you can't make
it sold out don't sweat it it's ten
[__] minutes listen if we keep doing
this we're just gonna get better and
better i don't like people seeing me in
a shitty state anyway
so i'd rather you see me when i'm
cooking with [__] gas this is free i
don't give a [__] how i show up here but
when you're paying the [__] heavy
duty and you're getting the babysitting
the whole thing i gotta show up with six
[__] bullets correct
what the [__] i love your [__]
with all my heart
stay black happy easter and we will see
you [__]
in preparation of 4 20.
stay black have a great week
see you next week
all right
we had a good time today it was time to
see you guys and just chit chat we'll
come back with the guests next week and
talk some [__] but the joint is brought
to you by relief band listen if uncle
joey tells you relief man works towards
anxiety
air travel car travel it helps from me
helps my daughter relief ben has been
critically proven to relieve and prevent
anxiety-induced nausea and vomiting it's
like the name says
if it's a band you wear on your wrist to
give you relief from nausea caused by
things like anxiety morning sickness
chemotherapy you could change the
intensity depending on how you're
feeling to make it stronger or weaker
relief band was there for me when i had
my surgery i got in the mail i didn't
know what the hell it was and bam it
works relief man is 100 drug-free
non-drowsy and provides lost
long-lasting relief and they just
released a relief banned sport it's
waterproof and it connects to your app
or android watch now relief man makes a
great gift for any time of the year for
your uncle and you know some people go
fishing they go on boats if you go to
reliefband.com and use promo code joey
you'll receive 20 off and free shipping
with no questions asked
30 day money back guarantee do yourself
a favor this is a gift mother's day is
coming father's day is coming this is
what you need right now they already got
a wallet and a tie and all that [__] go
to reliefband.com and use promo code
joey for 20 percent off plus free
shipping
the joint is also brought to you by cbd
[__] lion when it comes to cbd
cbd lion is the best i've been with them
for three years
and i just [__] love them and they
with me they love me so we got a perfect
match you want to start small start with
the tanks you get the 1500 milligram
tincture your head's gonna [__] blow
up get the kinesiology tape another
great one
anyway go to cbd lion read that third
party lab results
you see what you like get some cbd sent
the owls and don't forget about those
delta nine gummies i get them delivered
to your house with a 20 discount from
cbd line when you use code joey
i also want to thank blue chew listen
april showers bring may flowers what
does that mean you want a sling dick
with three hands it's time to plant your
seed you want a february baby let me
tell you something
blue chew is tremendous guys i love it i
love it comes a little package you put
in your wallet you can take it any time
any day day and night
the process is very simple you go to
bluechew.com
and talk to one of the licensed medical
providers once you're approved you
receive your prescription nobody knows
nothing there's no doctor's office
there's no pharmacy no guy without your
bra eyebrows beating you to death it
ships right to your door in a discreet
package
bluetooth tablets are made in the us of
a way cheaper than your pharmacy so if
you can benefit with a little extra
confidence when it's time to sling dick
blue chew can help and here's a special
deal for the joint listeners
try blue shoe for free when you use
promo code joey at checkout just pay
five dollars shipping that's
bluechew.com
promo code joey to receive your first
month free
visit bluetooth.com for more details i
want to thank blue chew i want to thank
relief band
i want to thank cbd lion and annette for
having our back this week but most
importantly i want to thank you savages
i'll see you [__] next week
monday morning
magoo happy easter
[Music]
you